here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna think
about all of that stuff which I've
worked out before and try and see what's
useful in this graph that I can work off
of the reciprocal so here's the first
thing the easiest thing generally tends
to be where's the vertical asymptote you
often get vertical asymptotes wherever
this guy equals zero
wherever y equals zero you get a
vertical asymptote so I can see one
immediately there I don't actually know
what its y-value is sorry what its
x-value years but it doesn't matter I
don't need to know its exact value to
know that it's going to be there because
that's where the intercept is okay in
addition to that I know as most people
skip this step but I'm going to
encourage you to do it in addition to
that I'm going to shade now over here
my reciprocal function I'm very
confident we'll be up in this area how
did I know that what information did I
use to work out that my reciprocal will
eventually go through here I think the
original function is positive in this
area so therefore my reciprocal will
also be positive okay by the same token
I've got the same guy over here so there
the original function is negative and
the reciprocal is also negative now one
of the things you will frequently not
every single time as you'll notice for
the next one but one of these you'll
frequently notice is you get a
horizontal asymptote of y equals zero
now my question to you is how did I know
that there was going to be a horizontal
asymptote in this case what information
told me that why would my reciprocal be
going toward zero what's the original
function doing over here on the right
the original function what's it doing
it's just getting huge right which means
for the reciprocal the denominator is
getting huge and that makes the whole
thing actually very small okay so over
here the original has large positive
values that means the reciprocal will
have small positive values look over on
the left over there the original will
have large negative values so the
reciprocal be small negative values but
still negative you can see I shaded it
right the last important points I want
are where y equals one and I can act
see three spots where there happens did
you notice them as well there's a y
equals one there's another one and
there's another one okay and now I'm
pretty much ready to go now I feel
comfortable but you may feel like no I
want a few more values right for example
some nice spots would be these guys
whoops that's not marked correctly I'm
gonna mark this in a different color
see these two here what do we call these
guys again what are they called these
are stationary points right now the
reason why these stationary points are
interesting to me is because if the
original has a stationary point think
about this look here's the here's an
original which had a stationary point
right what did you notice about the
reciprocal it also has a stationary
point the same spot right so when you
have a look at these guys see how
there's stationary points here I'm going
to predict they're going to be
stationary points in the reciprocal as
well and you can check out the values
right that looks to me that looks like a
three this is what I started with I
think this is three fifths I think you
guys taught me the reciprocal of 3/5 is
5/3
so 5/3 is 1 and 2/3 1 and 2/3 I'm gonna
place that about there see that one in
2/3 think is too high maybe a bit low no
I'm okay with that I'm okay with that
about point six six six six right and
then over here what's that value of
there it's one point four one point four
so that's um what's that seven over five
so the reciprocal is five over seven
which I'm going to place around there
okay and so you can see do you see how
it's like oh it's waving around you're
getting those cherry points I was
predicting all right I think I'm ready
to go
oh wait now one last point I missed the
point anyone noticed well last point you
all should have put on the negative one
thank you very much so down there down
there you can see on left hand side
there's negative one right there okay
I'm ready to go let's do the left-hand
side it's gonna be easiest there's the
left hand side okay this right hand
sides a bit weird but that's okay I can
work it out
hold on I'm gonna do that
shape and then I'm gonna do this kind of
shape there you go
can you just look up and compare your
graph with mine the blue graph
what do you think are you an agreement
right so you can see did I just get it
whatever okay
did you see I've got the sign I know
where I'm going positive I know where I
go low I know where I go high this
important thing with these red spots
right stationary pointing the original
gives you a stationary pointing the
reciprocal right okay it's the last one
on reciprocals if you already done this
calm you ever I want to have a look for
the rest of you go for it let's have a
look at this last one together okay I'm
gonna do it just the same way I did
before number one does this thing have
some symmetry it does it in fact it
doesn't say that any symmetry has a
particular kind as a name what kind of
symmetry is it starts with an e this is
even symmetry right yes nailed it okay
so can I ask you to put your pants down
to look up for a second there's an
important point the reason why I start
by thinking about symmetry is because if
I have a shape that is symmetrical I can
instantly have the amount of work I need
to do yeah because it's like if it's
symmetrical I just have to work out one
half and the other half does exactly the
same thing so now that I know it's
symmetrical I'm just gonna focus on one
half and then I'm gonna work all that
out and then I'm gonna do the other side
okay so the next I'm gonna do is some
shading I'm just gonna fix it on the
right hand side this part here the
original function is what sign it's
positive so the reciprocal should be
positive now when I shade you might
notice I'm actually not going to shade
forever I'm going to stop right there
because over here right over here the
original function doesn't exist yeah so
therefore when you take the reciprocal
of nothing you get where you get nothing
back right so the reciprocal is not
gonna exist over here because this one
doesn't either
okay you guys told me there is a
vertical asymptote where is it
it's a be more specific to is just a
number it's it it's an x equals two
right because that's a straight line
yeah so put that in if you haven't
labeled the equation of x equals two
please please do so right x equals two
now in all three of the previous graphs
I got a horizontal asymptote did you
notice that if all three of them I got y
equals zero right do I get a horizontal
asymptote for this guy now the answer is
no but the question is why like I got it
so many times before why don't I get a
horizontal asymptote for this guy hmm
what continues rustling now this is
really important just put everything out
of your heads I really want you to think
about this right because it's so easy in
masses just kind of follow a pattern but
not know why it is you can look at these
three in me like look I get horizontal
asymptotes all the time right
not all the time there is a feature that
all three of these original graphs have
that gives you a horizontal asymptote in
the reciprocal what do you say yeah okay
so wait what doesn't go below the x-axis
okay so you're saying I can't go
underneath here I see how it's gonna
stop okay that's kind of on the right
track but it's actually a slightly
separate feature that gives us the heart
what do you say that
okay you're you're on the right track
okay
hey think about this right why is this
value here why is it getting smaller and
smaller forever why is the reciprocal
getting smaller and smaller forever
answer everything about the reciprocals
from the original right
the original is getting bigger and
bigger forever right have a look at the
next one
original bigger and bigger and bigger
reciprocal small and smaller small same
deal here notice that even over here
right bigger and bigger and bigger
negative so that gives you smaller and
smaller and smaller negative now have a
look at our semicircle does it ever get
bigger and bigger and bigger the answer
is no it doesn't it never goes up to
here it never goes down to there it's
just kind of restricted in this little
box right now that other there was one
last important value probably noticed
it's the y-intercept what's the
y-intercept on the original two so the
y-intercept of the reciprocal is 1/2
okay by the way that's not just any
point what's this point here it's got a
name and I marked it in red before
that's a stationary point so I should
expect a stationary point here when I
have a look if you were to try a few
more values or one last value one last
one that's important one thank you
where's one there's one right there
what's the reciprocal of one one so I'm
going to go right through there I'm
ready to draw this thing right now just
be careful it's a weird shape strain to
have a question
if that's whoa if that's - that's one
isn't it
this is actually the particular critical
important point I was talking you and
Ian forgot to look for that's where it's
one yeah it's on the y-axis that's what
we're looking for okay so I'm just going
to quickly draw it you notice it's very
flat like that super flat right and then
when you have a look on this side it's
the same deal super flat like that
because of that symmetry that you guys
told me about right at the beginning
make sense now what's great about this
is this is a semi-circle reciprocal so
go to desmos right and one of the things
you can do in here is you can actually
say let's call this f of X now what's
the equation of a semicircle like what
goes over the top it's a square root
right having a look at this guy what's
the radius of this the radius is 2 so in
my equation I'm gonna have 2 squared
which is 4
and then I'm gonna have minus 1 x
squared there is my whoops there's my
semicircle and if you go and put into
your desmos put 1 over f of X right
ready for it BAM there we go
nailed it